show you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice ken
coleman ramsey personality number one
best-selling author and host of
the ken coleman show where we talk where
he talks about
getting you a job getting your career on
track getting into work
that you love joins me as my co-host
today so we can add that to the list of
things we'll talk about
i'll talk about anything because i'm an
expert on my opinion
so you jump in the phone number is
triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five eric is with us in raleigh to start
off
this hour hey eric what's up in your
world yeah hey dave i appreciate you
taking my call
sure um i actually called last week and
they said this was a call for dave
oh wow to call back i hope you brought
your a game i'm sure be an easy one for
you
i own a business and so i have two bank
accounts i've got
my personal bank account and that's
where i keep my three to six months
emergency fund um and then i've got the
business bank account and that's really
where my question is is
how do i approach how much cash to leave
in there
is it the same three to six months is it
all expenses is
you know kind of get your idea i'm on
baby step
six so i look at this lump of money in
there and
i'd like to put it on the house or do
something with it but i also want to be
safe
you know protect the business yeah okay
well that's very wise
so um i i use a separate
savings account at home just for an
emergency fund
there's nothing in it but an emergency
fund it's a money market account
and i keep three to six months of
expenses in there okay
just for home emergency phone it's not
in my checking account i don't recommend
combining them
the same is true in business and i use
we use a fairly sophisticated
tool we have a float account in our
business operating account that floats
anything
out of the uh checking into
uh overnight and it earns then money
market account rates each night
uh and then whatever is needed is
automatically pulled back in and so it
floats back and forth
but i i in a traditional checking
account i don't leave the emergency fund
in there in business in business we call
it retained earnings
and uh of course we recommend you run a
business the same way i run mine
and uh i'm consistent with i do run it
this way we don't borrow money here
and so however much cash we can get in
there is our line of credit
we're our own line of credit because we
don't have a line of credit our savings
account
is our line of credit so if we want to
buy equipment we want to expand
we want to launch into a new product
line
we want to buy another company we want
to build a building
we want to do anything we have to have
the cash
and so uh with all of that in mind uh we
if you're gonna live that way then
you're gonna want about six months worth
of cash in your business
of what it takes your business to
operate and um
i gotta tell you that didn't seem like a
lot of cash
at this time last year when everything
stopped
and everybody quarantined and everybody
went home and the world stopped
and everybody sat in uh trembling before
their televisions
and did nothing uh that didn't feel like
a lot of cash
it didn't it didn't feel like a lot of
pad i was wishing i had a year's worth
of cash
uh because i'm looking at a thousand
team members and i'm thinking if i burn
through this
cash they're not gonna have a job
because i don't borrow money
to keep them either and so i don't
borrow money so
given that then the more stringent you
are on that subject
the more you cash you'd have and i mean
ken you were sitting here as we're
having these discussions with our own
team members
about cash we've got you know here's we
told the team here's how much cash we
have
yeah and um and here's the real here's
the burn rate
and uh we have to have more money coming
in than going out or we start to burn
through that cash
and as we burn through that cash because
we're losing money
uh then that you know that approaches
the drop dead date in which people will
not be paid and we won't have a place to
work and so
we're talking reality wasn't it it was
very real and i think eric
here's what i would tell you i don't
think there's a wrong answer for
somebody who's on baby step six
you've obviously put a lot of cash away
in your business i don't think there's a
wrong answer i think you have to do what
dave saying here and let's put a real
emotion on this and you have to ask
yourself you know because
pam the pandemic was something none of
us had ever faced including dave or
anybody was like what we don't even know
what's going to happen
it's unprecedented yeah they're you know
your favorite word
but here's the deal eric i think you put
away uh if you feel like a year makes
you really really
comfortable with this kind of pandemic
if this were to happen again
if it's a year put a year away if it's a
year and a half put a year and a half
away because you're already in such a
great position
that you're going to be walking through
baby step six pretty soon anyway
don't overthink it just put an emotion
on and go this makes me feel good when i
lay my head down at night and then move
forward and i you know we felt pretty
good until there was absolutely
you know full stop and i think that's
what you have to look at for a small
business owner you have to look at that
what does full stop look like yeah
how would it affect us it's hard to
imagine a scenario where full stop
occurred
but we then we walked through one 12
months ago that's right and so uh the
good news was we never
actually had a single month that was not
profitable
and so we never even got into the cash
uh but i could tell you our cash
position today
is a whole lot better because we have
we've been building up cash because it
scared us yeah i mean you know it's like
wow yeah
and here's the thing our company has we
save a percentage of our profits to grow
retained earnings every month
it's a formula that we use out of our p
l when we do profits before we disperse
the profits
to the various uh people that are paid
off the bottom line
we set aside a percentage of it to
continue to grow
and we have never our growth curve has
been faster than our retained earnings
growth
and so we've never been able to get up
to a full six months
worth of cash and eve but we were close
but even then it wasn't enough and it
was millions and millions of dollars oh
for sure but
it's still it's just you thought well i
got millions of dollars here in cash and
it's just sitting here and
then all of a sudden it's like that's
not so much no it's got to be gone
yeah you know and it gives you these
this uh this uh you know
tightening of the stomach as it climbs
towards your throat and so
the beautiful thing is with no debt uh
you know we were able to keep that
number fairly low
that changes everything and so we don't
reverse those trends we don't borrow
money we always save money we're always
generous and we always live on less than
we make
these are biblical principles for
finance well i'll attest to this folks i
mean because we don't have debt as a
business
dave said all right we're going to cut
expenses we're going to we're not going
to do the things that we've normally
done
because we're gonna batten down the
hatches and see how long this storm
takes and you can do that when you don't
have debt you can say all right
it's uncomfortable but i can cut i can i
can save i can do those things and
cutting and saving
without sending people without sending
or laying people off
versus a lot of small businesses weren't
in a place where they could do anything
and so now they're taking the ppp loan
and we everybody knows what we think
about that
and what that does to you so i i think
as a small business person
i think it's okay to go i want to have a
goal of having a year's worth of
cash operating cash in the bank don't
have to we're not saying that's a
cardinal rule but it certainly doesn't
hurt when you're a small business owner
where
you've got a team of 20 or 10 but here's
the formula
the less debt you have and the more cash
you have the more options the survive
the higher your survivability probably
that's absolutely right the higher your
probability of survival is
and so and let me tell you who wins
those that stay open
it's the truth when you ride the roller
coaster there's a down
the fittest and there's an up there's a
down
and there's an up welcome to business
and oh by the way you're not the
exception out there
some people think they're smart enough
to outsmart it nope it's coming for you
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices and
they make it simple to shop
blinds shades and interior shutters with
easy online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
now heard on over 75 radio stations
across america sirius siriusxm
and an uber popular podcast oh and
youtube channel
he's everywhere so check him out
kencolman.com
ramseysolutions.com you can find him
there anything you need along those
lines
the phone number here triple eight eight
two five five two two
five you wanna talk about jobs you wanna
talk about career you wanna talk about
life and money
we are here for you tyler is in denver
hi tyler how are you
hey can you hear me okay absolutely
what's up
great um hi i'm a huge fan of your show
i've watched almost all your clips on
youtube
so i'm really excited to talk to you
right now um got a bit of a career
question for you
um my name is my name is tyler i
graduated from college in 2019
in engineering school i'm 24. i uh
i work for an engineering company i make
about a little under 90 a year
and um you say this
oh thank you a lot of times i hear you
say this quote on the on on youtube
um you know it's bad to have a mentality
of oh oh god it's monday thank god it's
friday kind of thing
and i'm just kind of wanted to elaborate
on that a little bit um i would say i'm
kind of in that boat
um i really enjoy where i work you know
i work with good people i think the
stuff
i do is technical and interesting but
you know obviously if i had the choice i
i obviously
wouldn't work in nine to five at a desk
all day um so i'm just wondering you
know is that a bad mentality to have how
can i get out of that or
or what can i do about these feelings
well let's just play this out you're 24.
you've got an engineering degree the
work
interests you but you gave us a big clue
i don't want to sit at a desk all day
and that's not
wrong to feel that way but let's look at
what the future
what what you want the future to be so
let's fast forward 34
44 what kind of work would you want to
be doing at this very moment what would
you say
yeah i mean i love what i do um you know
i love i love tech and i love
engineering and i'm a computer
programmer essentially
but um you know so i move up in those
ranks you know
start taking on project leads and and
stuff similar to that
but um but like i said you know it's
still a nine to five thing
um i think i'm conflicted more you know
the idea of like well
i'd rather be doing this or that you
know i'd rather be outside i'd rather be
you know with friends and stuff like
that
and i'm not saying obviously i don't
like my job because i do i i do
so you're all over the place so i want
you to say it's just like you just don't
want to go to work yeah because outside
and be with outside with my friends
that's great but that's not work
um what do you want to do i mean you
started to give us a clue there you up
the ladder
you're 24 first of all so you need to
relax you're in that entry
position uh and you're making almost 90
thousand dollars a year
so you're in you're on the ladder so
what does the ladder look like what do
you want to be
doing at 34 44 you want to work for
yourself have your own tech company what
is it i know you've allowed yourself to
think about it
say it what is it sure
um i mean i've never even really
considered the possibility of starting
something where i work for myself
i just kind of am under this assumption
that i'll be in some
some corporate structure okay forget
assumptions what are you
what do you wonder about when it's just
you what is the 45 year old you doing
professionally what have you allowed
yourself to imagine say it now let's
assuming you're working at something
yeah not playing with friends like
badminton in the backyard
yeah exactly no i i you know i obviously
i
i enjoy having a stable and steady
income um so that i don't want to change
obviously tyler um you know what is the
dream what i want to do
say it say it
i know you've thought it i've done this
enough tell me what you dream about
what i dream about when i dream about
i'm not going to be panicking here uh no
no okay so here's
just moving up in that moving up all
right so moving up tell me what moving
up
looks like what are you forget about job
title forget about how much money you're
making forget about how you get there
you're letting your brain run i want
your heart to answer this question
you love the work of engineering you
love that creative technical aspect to
what you do is that true or false
true okay then so if you want to keep
doing that kind of work
and moving up the ladder you need to
begin at 24 to go what does that ladder
look like
way up top start looking at that stop
focusing on well i'm at a desk eight
hours a day
well you're 24 man and paying dues for
you
is really good right now i mean you're
making almost 90 000
a year you're overthinking this start to
talk to engineers who have been at this
for 10 years
15 years 20 years what's the kind of
work you would love to do and if you
want to retire at 40
great there's nothing wrong with that i
mean are you supervising engineer
products in the field in the field which
gets you out of the office
in the future uh no i i work for a
website company so i'll be indoors most
of the time no i'm saying you might not
be working for the same company dude
yeah yes got it got it if you're doing
injury what kind of engineer are you
i'm a computer engineer a computer
engineer okay all right i had i had you
engineering buildings for a minute i'm
sorry
okay um
okay so you know you've just got to
decide i don't know of a situation i
can't think of a situation but i i'm not
an expert on your field
uh i've got about 300 of you working
here but none of them work outside
they all work in the building um and so
we don't have any
computers out in the amphitheater or the
park next door or around the fire pit or
the various places i mean i
actually have wi-fi out there you can go
out there and sit but um
yeah but uh a nice day but the vast
majority of them work inside the
building
so um yeah i think probably
what i would leave you with is this um a
there's nothing wrong with paying your
dues for a few years and sitting there
and while you're making 90 grand paying
your dues to ken's point is not bad
uh b and and so just plan on that b
it does not just because you do that for
two the next two years does not mean
you have to be doing that for two
decades you
get to choose i'll tell you one thing
that i know
one thousand percent chance over the
scope of my career
i'm one thousand percent chance your
world is going to change
computers are going to change i mean
when i
when i was your agent starting there
weren't computers
the personal computer was not very
personal
and so i mean back when the dinosaurs
roamed the earth it's hard to imagine
that but uh
feels like 20 minutes ago and then i've
watched the computer evolve
into these tiny little things in our
hands which will do more than
a whole building full of them would do
just a few decades ago so fast forward
your thing a few decades
uh you may be doing stuff from sitting
outside working on holograms i don't
know
something's going to be different yeah
and so and and we're not picking on
tyler
a lot of people get in this situation
dave this is what we do every day on the
ken coleman show people get a little bit
locked up
and so what we're pressing for is this
allow yourself to look
out and say what's the kind of work that
i think would fire my soul up
and at 24 you might not know that's the
reality he's
really young today you might my point is
with technology curve
today you might not see how you're quote
working outside
unquote uh doing your job but two years
from now
it might be going everybody's doing that
and here's what they're doing that's
exactly
i don't have any idea what's going to
happen but so you're the point is you
are not locked into this
for 40 years yeah there's no chance you
can't
do what you're doing for 40 years it
won't exist right
it won't even exist five years from now
that's right so start
problem solving in your head as an
engineer as a computer technology he
really enjoys the work there are clues
there so if you want to work outside
allow your mind to wander a little bit
and then go do some research here's what
i mean
what are some problems you want to solve
that are more outdoor in nature maybe
one day you've got your own company
that is anywhere you're in the truck and
you're moving around you're going from
site to site who knows
but you've got to start to look into
that and you don't overthink the fact
that well i'm in this indoor job right
now and i get it he's young
but you've got to allow yourself to
explore some things
and listen to those clues if you like
being outdoors a lot all right then
well then how are you solving the type
of problems you like to solve
and how do you take that creative
solving and that technical solving
ability and go okay how could i do it
out here
in this world and again not to pick on
him but it is a
normal thing in today's world
to go from high school to college
and your first job is you go to work
every day and you work all day
yeah and that's a new emotional
experience that's exactly right because
you've not done that
you know you and so literally what is
occurring is you're developing a
work ethic that you've not had to have
previously it doesn't mean you were lazy
before but you're experiencing the
emotional
bending of i've got to have the
discipline to go to work and work while
i'm
at work from nine to five and deliver
results so i can keep on working
amen i mean there's that's that's
grown-up land right there
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host
if you're feeling stuck or disengaged in
your current job if you dread getting
out of bed and going to work if you're
searching for a new job for any reason
our get hired live stream event on
tuesday april 27th
is for you it's a one night event and
you'll learn how to get clear
on what you do best get qualified for
the job you want
and get connected to real job
opportunities
time to take the next step and no matter
where you are what your situation is
there's hope
join me and ken coleman tuesday
20 april 27th to take control of your
career and start working towards what
you're born to do
tickets start at just 20 text hired
to 33 789 text hired
to 33 789
ken this is the second get hired event
you've done yeah we
pulled one together in june of last year
just as the pandemic was really starting
to rock the job market
and had a great attendance and a lot of
a lot of people helped and
here we are now just a year outside of
when things begin to shut down and we
have 16 people
that are unemployed for every job that
is available that's quite a
juxtaposition from a year ago where
there were more jobs available in
february of 2020
than there were people who are
unemployed so it is a competitive market
we got a lot of young people as you know
dave coming out of college and it's very
very competitive a lot of people who
want to switch
and it's going to be a great night i
should mention too there's a lot of
migration
yeah so uh we're going to have a live
crowd limited live crowd but we're
excited about that we love
talking to humans face to face so if
you're in driving distance of the
nashville area
uh those two tickets are going to go
fast but we are having a live crowd
that's going to be a lot of fun right
here in the gorgeous lobby of ramsay
solutions world headquarters so do
join us just check ramseysolutions.com
events events and the tickets are there
right there you can get the tickets for
the live audience if you want to be in
there if you want to do the uh
again the live stream it's only 20 bucks
ken will be covering a detailed
fun and funny but very clear path
to go from where you are to where you
want to go yeah we're going to give you
the edge so you can beat the competition
because it is a competition yeah there's
a lot of competitive out there
action out there right now for any
position and uh we've got
thousands of applications coming in at
ramsey
uh we're hiring 300 yeah you know in
this calendar year and we've got
we'll probably get before it's over
we'll probably have 30 000 applications
for those 300 positions true
and so you've got to learn how to set
yourself apart you've got to learn how
to push through to get hired with the
company you want ken can walk you
through all of that it's the get
hired event text the word hired
233 789 it's tuesday april 27th
20 text the word hired to
three three seven eight nine
adriana is with us in san diego hi
adriana how are you
hi thank you for taking my call i have a
question um we
have a hundred thousand dollars saved
and we don't know what to do with it
um we just started listening to your
show a couple months ago so now we're
lost okay um what do you suggest we do
it's a wonderful place to be lost
yeah i'd like to lose myself in a
hundred thousand dollars
not a bad thing yeah so you know what we
teach
is the shortest path from where you are
to wealth
uh and the goal being that when you're
wealthy you have margin in your life you
have the ability to be generous you have
the ability to
uh spend the time doing the things you
want to do
and serving others in the process so
that that's the reason for this whole
thing
and so we teach a thing called the baby
steps so wherever you are on the baby
steps is what i would do with that is
your home paid off
yes sir and you're 100 debt free
um well we owe about 12 000 on the car
and that's it
okay so now we have 88 000 because we
just paid that off
uh do you have an emergency fund other
than this set aside
of three to six months of expenses
um no we have a dozen i mean six
thousand dollars inside of that
okay okay so you need to figure out what
three to six months of expenses are
what's your household income about 120
okay so if we said three months expenses
might be
twenty five thousand dollars we'd set
twenty-five thousand in a separate
savings account
just for emergencies i just made that up
you decide what you wanna do
you paid off your twelve thousand dollar
car that's thirty seven thousand
uh so that leaves me uh sixty three
thousand dollars to do something with
uh do you have fifteen percent of your
income going into retirement
yes sir good do you have children
yes we have two uh nine and twelve how's
their college funds
um well we're saving for that too we're
doing a separate account for them but i
don't know how much is in there but just
putting
there i would sit down with your
investment advisor and see if you have
enough
on that already done if you don't we
might use some of that 63
000 for that otherwise you're what we
would call once you've done these other
things you would be at what we call baby
step
seven which is the last step there's
nothing left to do but they're there but
build wealth
and become outlandishly generous and so
uh you know if you don't need any money
for the kids college and so you have the
whole 63 000 available
then you're down to investing that in
some way
uh and or being generous with that money
in some way
and so i personally only do two kinds of
investing
i buy real estate that i pay cash for
so no mortgages and i invest in good
growth stock mutual funds
uh 63 000 in san diego will not buy you
real estate
and so you'll be investing in mutual
funds uh you don't have enough to pay
cash for a piece of
reasonable piece of real estate there uh
and i don't recommend long-distance
landlording
and so uh in your case 63 000 almost
if you even if you want to buy real
estate later i'm going to invest this
for now in some good mutual funds
with the goal of adding to it over time
to buy some real estate with cash
later on but follow a clear detail path
it's called the baby steps and you can
find it at ramseysolutions.com it's got
everything there
that you need scott switherson fort
myers hey scott
welcome to the dave ramsey show no it's
not his ramsey show
my bad what's up uh you guys are the tag
team that i've been waiting to talk to
so i appreciate your time um i've been
with the same company for about seven
and a half years
and i am part of a key employee group
and i was offered a business
succession plan that i signed up for
just over a year ago
you were offering a live stream a
business succession plan
so instead of a family business being
turned over to the two sons that work
there
there are two other employees myself
being one and someone else
that will be buying the business in
about eight or nine years
so he's giving us stocks or shares of
the business
to get up to fifty percent of the
ownership and then in about eight years
we'll have to buy him out
okay and i no longer want to do that
uh the direction of the company in the
last
year and four months has been horrible
and it's definitely run
more like a family business and i am not
the family name so
i'm looking to start my own business so
i need to be able to get out of this
business succession plan the only issue
is there is a three-year 150-mile
non-compete that i found out about after
i signed
how did you find out about it after you
signed you mean you signed something you
didn't read
uh he wouldn't allow us to i asked if
you signed something you didn't read
what are you in congress
i have done every every wrong move since
uh
since birth so unfortunately yeah i just
found you guys about four months ago and
i paid off my 401k loan because i did
that without
thinking about it so now i'm debt-free
with that
i have paid off 37 000
out of 73 000 in the last
10 months so i'm almost debt free i'm
getting there
but the business aspect of it i'm going
to start my own business and i just need
to know
well is this guy the type of guy that if
you go in and just uh
fall on your sword and beg for mercy
he'll let you out
uh from what i'm understanding no no
judge would follow a three-year 150 mile
um oh i disagree none competing
absolutely a judge will do that
okay that's absolutely unfortunate it's
in writing it's absolutely that's
absolutely enforceable
yeah okay ken coleman
i don't know if he's yeah yeah i don't
know if he is
it's more than 150 miles too yeah i
wow we're running into a break here yeah
i'll tell you what hang on we'll come
back from the break we'll talk about
a little bit more yeah and let's think
about what we're getting into here oh my
goodness what a mess
uh as a matter of fact we're not gonna
do that so
uh you wanna take him after the other
well you'll figure it out we'll announce
it when we come back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right ken so scott and fort myers
signed
a succession contract that included a
non-compete
for three years and 150 miles away he
wants to leave that and not do it and
open a business
that would violate that non-compete um
right quick before we do the debt free
scream what are we telling him
i think he's got to go in and beg the
mercy of the owner and say here's why
take the high road
and the directions change for me and uh
because you didn't allow us to read this
i didn't know about this and i just
i don't want to burn the bridge i don't
want to blow it up i want to go
and live my life can we come up with a
gentleman's agreement and tear the
agreement up
if he doesn't do that you can consult a
lawyer but you sign something that's in
writing so you gotta
you know you gotta talk to a lawyer yeah
and i i don't know about florida law
but i do know about tennessee law it's
completely unfortunate
it's in concrete and so then the third
thing is you may have to day job this
i appreciate the fact you want to go
start a business but i'm guessing
at the level that you are in as you
describe you're making good money
i'm always skeptical of somebody saying
i'm just going to go start a business
and i'm going to be able to take care of
my family and my finances if you can do
that
and you do it 151 miles away or whatever
the deal is great
i'd be very very careful about putting
all your eggs and starting a new company
basket that makes me nervous
you're either starting a day job and
riding your three years out or you're
moving
on and or number three you're starting a
different
field that's right to open a business
that is not violating the non-compete
i don't think you're going to beat this
non-compete you could try and you can
ask for
mercy and you can ask an attorney if you
want to get in a fight
but um but i you know it's just my
opinion and again i'm just a business
guy i haven't do not have a law degree
so you'd have to check with someone that
does in the florida market
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage corey
and elise are with us is it elise yes it
is
how are you guys we're great how are you
dave welcome where are you guys from
we're from cincinnati ohio
congratulations you're debt-free how
much have you paid off
we paid off 136 026
good for you how long did this take
about three and a half years
all right i love it and your range of
income during that time started out
right at about eighty two thousand
and we're ended at about 150. whoa wow
excellent
so what do you guys do for a living so
i'm a senior digital program manager for
a really big global
manufacturing company and i'm a personal
training manager for a big global gym
so wow lots of big global things
happening very cool
what kind of debt was this hundred and
thirty six thousand a mixture
yeah so a hundred over a hundred
thousand of it was student loans
obviously
so big sally may and then the rest was a
lot of ankle biters between
small cars uh uh consumer debt
credit cards um we also had two kids in
this time frame too so it was paying off
the medical debt
so you're kind of normal very normal
just bopping along
what happened three and a half years ago
what was your wake-up call
well um i actually grew up listening to
you
talk my mom went through her journey it
turned into a her own journey eventually
but she started with your plan so when i
married him
um he was our he's my nerd but he's also
the spender
so when we started working when i was
working while he was finishing school
he was starting to buy a lot of big
ticket items like thousands of dollars
worth of things that we did not
we could not afford so it was talking to
him and saying hey we should look into
dave ramsey he has a great program and
he was like no no i got this
and then he got bored on a flight one
day and it was delayed i think so he's
like i'll check it out he ended up
binging your podcast catching like
almost all the way up
and he was like yeah we're doing this
plan so he got back and we set it up and
my mom bought us financial peace because
again she went through it
and uh so we started there and then he i
mean every single app
everything that you have promoted he's
got he has set up he has walked through
and uh we've just been going forth ever
since because we knew where we wanted to
be
something about staring at the face of
the 136 000 i mean
i always knew that the goal was to pay
off the debt and as fast as possible
that was something i always grew up with
but it wasn't you know
it wasn't your plan and so it wasn't
until i went and faced all the numbers
and added everything up and i was like
it was just this mountain staring at us
and i was like i can't do this by myself
anymore and we need to figure something
out
do you remember the conversation in your
head when you listened to the first
minutes of a podcast of one of our
podcasts and something happened and you
start going
okay i want to learn a little bit more
okay i want to learn a little bit more
oh god
i got to do this i mean tell me kind of
how that worked yeah so for me it was
it was just thinking about um i was it
was always day to day it was how do i
get to the next day how do i get to the
next day
and something in the first podcast that
you that you spoke to me was
really focusing on kind of the the
future and the why
and when you started talking about
retirement and kids college and trying
to change your family tree that was what
kind of changed me and realized
that i need to stop looking at tomorrow
and i need to start looking at you know
the next 10 15 20 40 years from now
yeah we want to make sure that we break
the mold we break the chain from where
we've grown up where our parents have
grown up and that we set our kids up for
a much better future than
we originally had thought so here's what
i want to ask because people get this
they listen and they the baby steps make
so much sense there's really no denying
them
yeah but there's a difference between i
i i see how that works to
i believe i need to do that there's an
emotional
trigger i'm just curious you're the guy
that built that buying the big toys
she kind of ratted you out there and i
saw you smile you liked the big toys to
big sacrifices
what did you got what was the emotional
change to where you guys said all right
we're all in on this
um i think it was realizing that i could
get much bigger toys
after after everything paid off you know
what i mean that works
i like it i like it there's a little
like no one else so later i can
live and give like no one else that's
very cool
and he literally spent one of these
sessions watching financial peace
because you talk about beans and rice
rice and beans
he literally made rice and beans and was
watching one of the videos from
financial peace because he's like i
gotta do what dave says i gotta live
like no one else so i can live like no
one else i said that that does not mean
literal
beans so i saw you win we can do more
than that did you put a little spice in
them did you try to make him taste
better now
not by much i don't think he's like i
gotta do what dave says
i gotta get there we gotta get there so
fast and he hit it hard and it was truly
a big change a very it hit him hard
you keep talking about him hitting it
hard were you on board were you doing
with him on this
i was the one that first brought it up i
know i played that part yeah
yeah then it sounded like he turned like
the tables turned a little bit no he uh
okay so you guys were you guys were
working together in sync yes it was um
because i'm the saver and i'm the free
spirit so
all you're saying is it was easy for you
it was just kind of clear
yes it made sense it was logical to me
when my mom first started going through
it so that's why i had mentioned it to
him it was just making sure
he saw the same logic that we were both
on the same page with that
and then it was from that point on
keeping him
calmer about it because like i said he's
sitting there eating rice and beans and
i'm saying honey we can go buy
a little bit more from the grocery store
we can live a little bit more
so it was just about then working
together he's go big or go home he
oh yeah it was hard in the beginning but
as we you know as we started to get
lockstep and we started to kind of build
and grow our relationship it got
a lot easier as we got towards the end
and yeah yeah we were able to see once
once the light was at the end of the
tunnel i mean the last 50
just really rolled out very very quickly
right and it helped our communication in
a lot of things too because finances are
obviously a big struggle and
we had only been married for about a
year or two when we first started so it
was just
it had really beefed up our
communication and we went forward from
that all right well let's get cason and
miles into the picture how old are they
cason is three and a half miles is 16
months all right very cool all happening
while this was happening
yeah very good stuff all right it's
corey and elsie and cason and miles from
cincinnati
136 000 paid off in three and a half
years
making 82 to 150 i'm so proud of you
guys
we got a copy of rachel cruz's new book
new york times bestseller
know yourself know your money as our
gift congratulations count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three
two one
[Applause]
that's how it's done you have to have
you talk about all the time your why
needs to make you cry you have to have
something that's
more noble than just i want to feel
better yeah that desired future is so
huge and if
you as a couple can get on i said we
want to change our family tree
that's what it's always been about when
you say that you're gay
and you mean it oh yeah you will
sacrifice today to win tomorrow no
question
adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good
and obviously we're looking at a couple
of adults there very very well done what
rock stars that's amazing it's amazing
by the way you feel
good when you do all the good down the
line it'll feel good when you're
hustling when you're sacrificing when
you're being diligent
but it feels really good when you cross
the finish line and every time we see or
hear a debt-free scream
i promise you folks those folks feel
real good yeah i mean 136
thousand dollars lighter fantastic
that's a lot
and uh and by the way there was no
student loan forgiveness no they paid it
off
dug themselves out there you go that's a
neat idea
i mean wow pretty incredible that puts
this hour of the day
of the i did it twice this hour well
you've been doing it for 30 something i
know this hour of the ramsey show there
it is in the box
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman
ramsey personality host of the ken
coleman show
where he talks about career and jobs
every day
is my co-host today and what that means
is you can talk about career and jobs as
well as money or anything else you want
to talk about
we're here to help you with your life
open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple
eight eight two five five two two
five amet is with us in buffalo new york
hey eamon what's up
hi dave thank you for taking my call
sure how can we help um
so so i had a question about uh finances
so
i'll explain the situation uh me and my
wife uh
were both residents my wife graduated
residency
last year i'll be graduating this year
so during our residency we were able we
had whatever money we were able to save
we invested it it's a small amount of
money so i was
okay doing it but with my wife getting a
new job and
me graduating and soon to get a new job
the amount of salary we have
uh i i find it difficult handing that
amount of money
so my question was like when should i
get a financial
uh advisor because i have talked to a
few people
uh but i i just i'm not able to trust
them
but at the same time i'm afraid handling
that much amount of money which
i have never seen in my life good for
you you're being very
wise on a whole lot of fronts so here's
what
the mistake that um that a lot of people
fall into and it sounds like you're
starting to uh and it'll solve both of
your problems
sometimes people want a financial
advisor in their head
they meet that means they have to take
over and run their life and
uh we have to trust them um instead
i use a a a financial
uh to do investments with
but i make the decisions and the way i
make the decisions is
his job is to present options to me
ideas to me and to teach me something i
didn't know before
and so much like you've studied in your
medical career to learn to be an expert
in that
you won't have to study nearly as hard
on money it's not that complicated
but you're going to have to learn a few
basic things
from a good financial
uh from a good investment broker or
investment advisor
and they say they are advising you
they're not telling you
they're not it's not a babysitter you're
not turning your money over to them and
just hope it works out
they're saying this is advice and with
advice means you're going to learn a
little bit okay i don't understand that
and by the way the rule is you don't
work with a financial
advisor that doesn't have the heart of a
teacher if they have the heart of a
salesman they're slimy
run if you feel like you need to have a
shower after you met with them
run and the other rule is don't put
money in anything you don't understand
and then you don't end up with being one
of those broke doctors
and broke doctors are there's more of
those than there are broke musicians
right that's that's what my fear is
because on your show you'd say that
doctors have doctoritis you know
they do uh so that that's what i'm
afraid about that you know i
i'll squander the money that i earned
and that's why i'm looking for a
financial advisor at the same time
i had talked to a few people and i i
just i just have difficulty trusting
them with my money
yeah you don't trust them with your
money you trust them to teach you
because you trust you yes right
and you must trust what dave just told
you let's just rewind what he said you
should be writing this down going okay
wait a second i'm in control
if the if the financial advisor gets
frustrated with you
and they don't want to teach you and
explain the questions that you've got
you don't understand the financial move
that dave said
then don't do it and and you get to
interview several people you need to be
meeting with some smart investor pros
yeah click through ratesolutions.com
click smart vester at
ramseysolutions.com
and that will help you line up with
someone that has the heart
of a teacher now here's the other thing
i don't want to
squander my money you said now let me
make sure
you mean you don't want to make a bad
investment that you didn't understand
and it
be and lose the money is that what you
mean correct yes
okay not squander it like i'm going to
overspend and be undisciplined hold
on no no both of us are
are quite frugal so i'm not worried
about that i'm worried about
like if i put in the wrong investment
and i lose that money yeah
exactly because you know sometimes i've
run into and you were not saying this
but just for the sake of our audience
sometimes i run into someone who comes
into a lot of money
and uh uh sometimes i uh someone who's
very young for instance in uh in the
music world or in nashville
they become very popular and they got a
lot of money also and they don't have
the maturity
to control the situation and that's no
one can give you that that's called
growing up but you've already got that
obviously okay
so we're frugal we're not going to
overspend we're not going to do
something stupid but
you don't want someone you know like
i've heard people
say stuff like well i called my
financial advisor and he told me i
couldn't buy a car
well it's not his job to tell me whether
i can buy a car or not
i'm going to decide if i'm buy a
freaking car i put the money in the
dadgum account
i can decide i'm a big boy i can decide
i'm a grown man
i can look at the numbers and go i can
afford this car i can't afford this car
i don't need to ask someone's permission
to do crap with
my money that's right and so that's when
you that's when you handed it over and
somehow you've gotten someone who's
babysitting you
and that is not what you do that's how
people get screwed
that's how they lose all their money and
they make a lot of money and they end up
with none so here's the trick
don't put money in something you don't
understand don't work with anyone
in the financial world real estate
agents insurance
agents investment brokers
estate planners tax people
don't work with anyone in the financial
world that does not have the heart of a
teacher
my poor tax guy has to explain our
infinitely confident complicated tax
returns
enough that i i'm not just signing them
because he put him in front of me and
that's the key
dave still has the power and and and i'm
you have the power as a doctor here
would be the analogy
i'm sure you've had somebody show you
how to use a medical device before
and you don't use it on a patient until
you know that you know that you know
that you know
how to use it and you have the same
control i'm not going to do that
until i understand how to use it you are
in control here
you're not giving over any control and i
love your spirit but again
there should not be a spirit of fear
here go to ramsey solutions.com
interview three five seven smartvestor
pros until you get a good feel
a good chemistry and that they're
willing to explain things to you because
as dave said he doesn't sign
on the tax form until he understands
what he's signing yeah so amy
you can just pile up the cash that's
true too
if that's all you understand until you
understand more i had a young man that
was a nfl football player come in and
sit down with me about two years ago he
and his beautiful little wife
and uh i mean they were like ken and
barbie
right and uh he said i gotta tell you
dave you're just gonna kill me i said
why am i gonna kill you what'd you do
he said i'm so ashamed i'm like what are
you ashamed of and he goes i'm such a
horrible investor and i'm so
how are you a horrible investor what did
you do and he goes i have 35 million
dollars
in a savings account
i'm not gonna kill you i'm gonna kiss
you you're a
he goes yeah well i i could have
invested it and i went yeah you probably
should have invested it but guess what
you didn't do
you didn't freaking lose it yeah you got
35 mil in the bank you didn't lose it
yeah
in the nfl that's called touchdown right
unbelievable baby now we can teach you a
little bit about investing and
wade out into the shallow end of the
pool and learn to swim into the deep end
it'll be all right
that's a good starting point son we're
gonna be okay
all right goodness gracious this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
you know healthcare has gotten to be
ridiculous
it puts people you know on the brink and
so it would have put us on the brink
had we not had chm chm saved our life
same document financial life christian
healthcare ministries or chm
is not health insurance but it is a
budget-friendly option and the original
health cost sharing ministry for
christians
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
april is here folks and you know what
that means it's national
financial literacy month we celebrate
financial literacy
every year and we want to celebrate the
hard work and dedication that teachers
give every day with our teacher
appreciation giveaway
it's sponsored by mint mobile the
affordable premium
wireless provider teachers can enter to
win
some amazing prizes like five thousand
dollars cash
to use however they like and you can go
to daveramsey.com
teacher to enter there is of course no
purchase necessary if you're not a
teacher share it with a teacher you know
ramsay solutions dot com
slash teacher ramsey solutions
dot com slash teacher
now can most people i was doing this at
my house one night at a dinner party not
long ago i said tell me about a teacher
that you remember and a few people
out of a whole bunch standing around
remember negative
teachers but almost every one of them
brought up a teacher that changed the
trajectory of their life
teacher is a big deal big deal uh joy
bryant
my high school speech teacher uh
probably outside of my parents had the
biggest impact on me
and uh write about it my first book one
question you can get at
ramseysolutions.com yeah
but uh i write about that and she to
this day taught me a very important
lesson
and speaking of great teachers we've got
one from north high school
in uh dillsburg pennsylvania
shannon trussell is with us hey shannon
how are you
hi dave i'm good how are you good is
trossel correct did i pronounce that
correctly
it's true okay thank you i didn't want
your i don't want your kids making fun
of you later yeah
yeah right yeah i better get it right
because it's my fault
okay cool so tell us what's going on
with you
so um i've been teaching personal
finance now
for seven years and um we started out
with less than 50 students in the class
and now we're up to over 200. wow
yeah it's really great and it's grown so
much
a few years ago i petitioned our school
board to make
this course a graduation requirement and
now it is
wow look at you wow so foundations and
personal finance our curriculum you've
been teaching it for seven years and
it's grown to 200 students
now to grow 200 students because it
became popular
or because it became mandatory well it
only just became mandatory
it grew because of its popularity
parents and community members saw the
value in this course
and you know students were talking with
their friends
and hey you got to take this class and
it it's really
snowballed it's great yeah and guess
what
you're one of those teachers that we
were just talking about that's how
i mean because let me tell you you can
take our wonderful curriculum and screw
it up if you mail it in
you don't mail it in girl you bring it
you bring it in the classroom you bring
it all the way to the school board the
parents know about you the students know
about you
you're one of the teachers they want to
go to your class i know that that's why
i grew
right yeah that's right dave i
appreciate that
look at you how long you've been
teaching um 17 years
wow we really appreciate you what are
you seeing the kids
getting most out of foundations and
personal finance our curriculum
um i think i think the thing that's the
most important
is i do what i'm asking them to do
my husband and i have gone through um
financial peace years ago and when
the opportunity came to teach a course
in personal finance i volunteered
immediately i knew exactly what i wanted
to teach and exactly
the program i wanted to use and that was
yours
and i just i have a personal connection
to the course and to the material so
when i'm teaching it to my students
everything i'm telling them is fact like
this is what i did
here's how you can do it and the
the questions they ask me are more
personal but i'm i'm giving them
information
and you know tips and tricks that i know
have worked because i do what i'm asking
them to do
no that's everything so what is what
subject
out of the curriculum do you think
resonates the most with them on average
um boy
that's a great question i think um
the one on income and careers yeah where
we write out
resumes and we practice interview skills
we have such a great connection with our
community
that i reach out to several different
community
business leaders in our area they
volunteer their time and they come in
and we do mock interviews with our
students
and it's really it's really neat the
kids
dress the part the guys come in in suits
and ties the ladies come in
you know looking on ten it looks great
and then um i had one student actually
about three years ago with his mock
interview
it turned into the real deal and by the
end of the interview i kept thinking why
is this taking so long
so i i stepped in the room to check out
what was going on
and they're shaking hands agreeing on a
starting salary i'm like what
so a senior in high school has a
full-time job as soon as he graduates
he's been working there for three years
that's what it's about that's what it's
about
so let me ask you what do you remember
the job what kind of what kind of
business or industry did this kid go
into yeah it was um
he was working for a general contractor
in construction
oh wow that's the truth electrical
specifically yes yeah
yeah that's fabulous that is a great
story i want to ask that's a great
professional story i was just curious in
the seven years you've been teaching
foundations in personal finance
is there a kid a story uh whether it
happened recently or they came back
later
and it's it's a real testimony to them
doing what you taught them
absolutely um i mean i could give you
lists i'm sure
um i mean i got an email probably right
around christmas from a student who
just thanked me for you know he he took
the class but he
even said in his email you know i took
it but it was like oh i heard it but
the one thing i like about the course
that we do is they get to take their
textbook with them
so he was telling me in his email you
know i pulled out my book
and i was flipping through and i'm
looking for the section on
you know roth iras and investing and he
got a new job and he was like i wanted
to
do this right and started his retirement
savings
from day one because of the information
he had in his hand
that is so cool he's going to be so
wealthy all because of you
that is so well done well shannon
trussell
in pennsylvania at north high school we
salute you
as one of those teachers that uh
thousands and thousands of people like
you all across america that change
people's lives and
we honor you and uh it is financial
literacy
month and we are honoring teachers with
a five thousand dollar cash giveaway
no purchase necessary if you're a
teacher just go to ramseysolutions.com
teacher and sign up we want you we want
you to be in the drawing for that we
want to say thank you
we want to salute you and uh there's
lots and lots of shannon's out there
yeah instructing all because they want
to impact the lives of young people and
i gotta say you know beyond just what
she's done in the classroom
and impacting these young people to go
to the school board which as you know
local politics is about as tough as it
gets in politics
and for her to take that to the school
board and sometimes that's a tough
proposition and kudos to the school
board say you know what
this is the kind of stuff that really is
going to have an impact long
beyond the high school diploma good on
the leadership there
and the principal in the administration
yeah and you know since we teach kids to
not borrow money i'm
sure that's popular with a local banker
that's what i'm getting at yeah there's
there's always some politics you know
plus there's that dave ramsey guy you
know he's a
controversial he's a cult leader and
leading these kids astray
you never know man that guy that guy
he's a rough old boy
yeah so that's fun way to go shannon
thank you so
much now 48 of the high schools in
america
are teaching wow and we've taught
millions and millions and millions of
students
with personal foundations in personal
finance our high school curriculum and
so
that means half the high schools in
america don't have it still we've got
more work to do yeah
so some of you guys if you're a teacher
your administrator out there get in
touch with us we'll help you get the
curriculum into your school
and get it done because uh i love having
these people on the debt free stage just
say you know when i was in high school i
went through your stuff and when i got
out of college i thought
i better do that stuff and here i am
doing my debt free screen
so there you go this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
marcus is with us hey marcus how are you
i'm doing great how are you guys
doing better than i deserve if you're on
that stage you can only mean one thing
you're debt-free that's right that's
right way to go man how much you pay off
so i paid off 21 000 and the total of
the loan was actually
32 000 but my parents had paid off that
first portion but i didn't want that
burden so i went ahead and
paid off the 21 000 on my own way to go
very cool
and uh your how long did this take you
it took about 10 months
10 months and your range of income
during that time so i was a full-time
college student
and i got a job at a coffee shop
and i was making eight dollars an hour
plus tips but i was also running my own
kind of part-time business i do wedding
videos any kind of marketing photos and
stuff
and so i was finding anything that i
could do to just
make money and put it towards his debt
so uh
and how were your living expenses taken
care of
so i was actually really blessed my aunt
on my mom's side lives in corpus christi
as well and she let me live with her for
free for
the entirety of my college wow and so
it was it was a really sweet deal i had
my own car so you just had to make two
or three thousand dollars a month and
you could throw it at this
and be done in 10 months exactly wow
good for you man
way to go and so is that about what you
made during that 10 months about uh 25
000
or so i would estimate i made around a
little around 30.
okay all right very good man
congratulations how old are you i'm 21.
wow have you graduated i did i graduated
in december
a degree in what communication way to go
man yeah
and corpus christi so which school texas
a m corpus christi go islanders gotta
give a shout out
all right very cool that's good man way
to go
and that that is a reasonably priced
tuition i bet yeah and
it was really helpful not living on
campus or in housing
and not having to pay an extra eight
thousand dollars yeah a year or a
semester yeah eight thousand dollars
helpful yeah that's
awesome man congratulations so have you
landed the big job
uh yeah with myself there we go
i i saw i run my own business down in
corpus cool doing photography and
weddings yep photo and video
all right and the communications degree
helped you probably probably got some
skills doing that didn't you yes
yeah and so it's kind of funny i have a
degree sitting in my living room and i
work for myself
so it's hilarious i love it
[Laughter]
way to go probably gonna make more money
than you've ever seen that's the hope
hey well done and actually people are
starting to get married again so they
and they might like to take a picture of
it yeah so good for you man
congratulations
so what put you on this journey ten
months ago so
i i went without a car my freshman year
of college and my aunt
is a police officer and she drove a unit
all day and so
i would drive her to work and she would
let me use her car
throughout the day so i would uh drop
her off and pick her up that was the
deal and then i could use the car
whenever
and then going into my sophomore year my
parents helped me finance
a brand new car 32 000
uh 2019 in 2018. at the time
i knew absolutely nothing about money
and so neither today
yeah and so i um
i was just happy that i got a car yeah
and i wasn't thinking about it we had a
535
car payment whoa and they were making it
and so
to me it was it was in my name but they
were making the payment
and so then a couple months later i was
kind of just sitting around thinking
you know i really don't know anything
about money i'm a sophomore in college
and
i didn't learn anything in high school
about money i learned what slope
intercept form is
but i don't know how to pay taxes i
don't know how to write a check
come on and so i've got the pythagorean
theorem
but i can't balance the check right
exactly and so i figured i should
probably learn a little something about
money now that i'm you know in college
and so
i looked up finance podcasts this guy
named dave ramsey popped up
so i listened to it i listened to the
first episode about 40 minutes and i was
hooked and as soon as i heard you
mention something about car loans i said
what have i done and so that really just
lit a fire and then i kind of did dave
ish for a little while and then my
senior year
i set a goal in february of last year to
pay off
uh the entirety of my debt which was the
remainder on the car
the 20 21 000 wanted to pay it off
before i graduated because i went to
school paid for uh took out
no loans i got grant scholarships lived
with my aunt
um and then anything i mean you were
smart all the way until you did a 35 000
32 000 car yeah yeah and so i um
yeah it was it was anything out of
pocket i paid you know i was paying
about 800
a semester just out of my own pocket um
to not take out loans and it was
definitely worth it and so
i paid off the car the day before i
graduated college last december
so yeah that's fun it was really fun
that's
that that's uh man that's like a rim
shot like
yeah you're right i love it good for you
man congratulations how does it feel
it feels awesome it's so nice man you
ever go back into it
absolutely not you're done i'm done
forever forever
cool well your aunt gave you a wonderful
gift she did i'm so
thankful so i know when she sees this
just hey no i'm so thankful for you guys
yeah that's pretty incredible very well
done who was your biggest cheerleader
during this 10 months
um i would say my closest friends were
my biggest cheerleaders my parents of
course
too um i got two of them sitting right
here
everywhere every i had so i had a little
chart a little paid off that chart that
i would color in
blue and green the colors of my school
yeah and uh every time i
got they were little increments of two
hundred dollars so every time i
got 200 400 just mark one off and i
would just be so excited like hey
i'm this much closer just that visual
representation of i'm this close to
paying it off
and so it was such a blast i have
another friend at the church we go to
her name's amanda and every she's
actually debt free she's working on
paying off her house
oh wow so anytime it was really clo
it was really cool because it was like
hey i just paid off 400 more dollars
and so i would show her and it was you
know it was just an awesome time
very cool well congratulations all right
when people ask
how'd you do that how do you pay off
debt what do you tell them the secret is
a lot of self-discipline yeah i think so
i think my self-discipline is is really
strong yeah going after
you know after those 10 months don't be
afraid to say no
and if you look at it this way you're
saying no
now to say yes forever right and so
i love uh very good life i love
taking people out to eat lunch and you
know just hey let me take you to lunch
and let's hang out
right um at the church i go to if
someone's new i would love to
you know let's go get coffee let's go
get lunch and you know being able to do
that not have to put on a credit card or
worry about paying something off so
what's your church you attend it's
called the net fellowship in corpus
christi great yeah very cool
i want to ask you this because you you
said something about self-discipline i
think we all get that but i'm also
impressed that you swallowed your pride
maybe you don't even think of it this
way but for a young college guy to live
with his aunt
yeah right college you know for some
people i want to get out on my own i
want to live with
roommates i want to do the whole college
life and this was not just a sacrifice
financially and hard work you also said
i'm going to live with my aunt what
would you say to a young person who's
going
and i want to do all the things was
college less for you are you any less
excited because of that
no college was a fantastic experience
for me i could have easily
my dream school is tcu texas christian
sure and you know it was
it was just something i couldn't afford
and i did not want to take out loans to
to go there and
pay off loans for 30 years rather than
go to a paid for school and live with my
aunt for three years
with no loans to pay off afterwards well
plus you got built-in security she's a
police officer
that's nice it's actually her her and my
uncle are both police officers
fairly safe they're there i'm thinking
we're in good shape and you got to
behave yeah
yeah yeah lots of good accountability
there yeah
well well done marcus we're proud of you
brother congratulations
very very well done and you got a great
start man i mean you're coming out of
school completely debt-free
starting your own business it's the
everything sounds bright and rosy we
just need shades man for your future
life is good yeah so well done marcus
from corpus christi
texas we got a copy of rachel cruz's
latest new york times bestseller for you
know yourself know your money
21 thousand dollars paid off in 10
months making
30 000 during that time count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
quick shout out real quick i know we
don't have much time will choi
tim stowe josh gavin cece and april
we're going on a helicopter tour tonight
i told them we have a surprise and i
would tell them on the show
helicopter tour downtown nashville paid
for in cash
three two one i'm debt free
what a cool guy i mean he's a giver i'm
gonna live like no one else and so later
i'm taking my friends on a helicopter
tour of downtown nashville that's right
live like no one else so later you can
live and give
like no one else man he's so set up it
really is i i hope he caught what he
said now i take people out hey can i go
to lunch with it can i encourage you
probably teaching them the steps as well
the baby steps so you
truly can give not just your money but
your time
love his story love is lots of margin in
that lots of margin that's right lots of
generosity
he is so set up that's he's gonna do so
well
oh man what a great guy this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today our question of the day
comes from blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mismeasure you screw up you pick
the wrong color
they'll remake the window blinds for
free you get free samples free shipping
and new promos
all the time to save even more always
use the promo code ramsey
it's magic it'll get you a good deal
today's question comes from andrea in
tennessee she asked
i'm moving into a different role at work
but there hasn't been any discussion of
a salary change if it doesn't come up
soon
how should i bring it up humbly and
clearly
now you want to walk into that and say
hey i just want to follow up we've been
discussing
this different role and we've yet to
talk about
what the comp looks like for that role
when you think it's the right time we'd
love to discuss that you know you can do
that face to face or
via email i always prefer face to face
so they can see your
humble spirit this is not an abnormal
thing to bring up
so the next time you're with that leader
i would bring that up and
you know if they're going to keep
kicking that can down the road that
should be a bit of a red flag
but assuming that everything's healthy
and we're serious and the conversation
continues to progress you need to bring
it up that way
you know the longer we've been
discussing that without making any
discussion in comp
change the more and it's not anything
she needs to do but it's just for the
rest of you out there listening if
you're
leading people uh you need to do a
better job
that's leading than that that's correct
so all you gotta do is just think like
you would think if you were in this
situation so you're talking to somebody
about a different role
if you were if the roles were reversed
you'd want to know what the comp is
hello everybody does it's the first
thing someone thinks about well what the
responsibilities are can i do the job
can i be competent can i
am i going to screw myself up by taking
on something i can't do
and what are you going to pay me that's
correct i mean what's the comp and it's
like
golly you get way down in some
discussion
and you know i actually had that happen
one time uh where
they were going to give me a pay cut oh
yeah i've heard you tell that story yeah
so i quit
right they were getting me after i was
their number one sales guy they were
giving me more responsibility going to
pay me less per
deal and i was gonna i mean i had to do
more deals to get the same number of
dollars into my household
and they were all happy that they were
promoting me
and i'm like you stupid corporate people
can't add right
and you know all they do is just talk
about that real early in the process and
i would have truncated it but no it gets
all the way down into the thing
oh sure that's a leadership failure at
some point now if it's been
one discussion about it that's not a
leadership failure but
but just keep in mind leaders that your
people won't know why they're gonna get
paid
that's really not rocket science
jennifer is in tampa florida hey
jennifer how can we help
hi good afternoon thank you so much for
taking my call dave and ken
um i thought you guys were gonna be the
best people to answer
well give me help with my predicament so
i'm trying to figure out if i should
keep my current job or if i should start
pursuing
another opportunity so um a little bit
about my situation
is i currently work for a non-for-profit
so
um the work that i do is really good as
far as giving back to the community but
the pay
is um pretty low compared to what i got
paid in the past but there's no
benefits but a lot of flexibility versus
um finding a job at the hospital
which does pay more but it's a lot more
rigid but it also has
benefits and could be a little stressful
so i kind of wanted to get your guys
take on that
well i got to tell you when somebody
calls the ken coleman show i never make
the conversation about compensation and
benefits because that eventually wears
off it always feels good when we get an
opportunity it feels good somebody wants
me
and when there's more compensation that
feels good when there's
benefits that feels good but right now
you're talking about how the non-profit
job you've already given us a little bit
of a clue that that
the values line up that you're doing
work that's creating a result that
matters deeply to you
but it's low pay but i have flexibility
so this is all these these extrinsic
motivators that you're mentioning these
are like outward things i want to know
where do you want to end up do you want
to continue to do the work you're doing
uh that that is aligned with this
non-profit or do you want to get into
health care and work in the hospital
what's the take the money out of it for
a second what do you want to do
10 years from today i'm so sorry
um so um so the end goal is ultimately
i want to go back to school to be a
dietitian so regardless i am going to be
doing a career change
the reason why i was considering the
hospital is because
um for your after you get your master's
you have to do an internship at a
hospital regardless so i figured that if
i put my foot in the door
yes ma'am allow me to allow me the
opportunity
plus um after six months they start
paying for your tuition
ding ding ding jennifer that's a
no-brainer that's a no-brainer here's
why
you need more money are temporary
everything's temporary and you're going
to go back to school to be a dietitian
so this gives you the money you need to
cash flow your school
more money i make i'm saving and i'm
cash flowing school to be the dietitian
secondly
they start paying for things you start
getting in the door in the hospital so
when it comes time to get out of school
and get that experience this is a
no-brainer take the hospital gig don't
even think twice about it it's the right
move
it gets you to where you want to go
that's right which is
is to become a dietitian uh it pays for
the school
it gives you the internship and it gives
you more money in the process
and oh well a little bit of stress but
that's part of the
price you're paying to get all this
other free stuff for a short period of
time
10 years from today the likelihood is
you're not working in either one of
these if you live your dream goal right
yeah that makes sense so let's take the
shortest path
and the least expensive path sorry about
that um how do you guys handle like
stress because i've never been the
greatest at handling stress
let's define that because everybody's
definition of stress
is very personal what are you worried
about in this hospital job you've heard
something or you've created something
that may not be based on fact let's
break that down what is the stress
you're worried about
so um so me as a person i'm a very
big free spirit so i work for corporate
america for
for many years and i felt like i was
just draining my soul away which is kind
of why i decided to go
a different route and try the
non-for-profit and i felt like i was um
giving back to the community which i am
so
you felt yeah that's true
you're not stuck now you're on a plan
yeah
the stress is the rigidity you said the
word rigid early on in the phone call
and so you're worried about the rigid
schedule you also mentioned what you
love most about this non-profit is the
flexibility you're gonna have to get
over this i'm just gonna be really
honest with you and say that
there is a great line from one of my
favorite movies that says the the the
father's talking to the son he says you
do what you have to do
so you can do what you want to do and
this is the price of admission
you want to lose weight you're going to
have to exercise and eat healthy
if if you want to put on muscle you got
to get to the gym
and you got to really work out and it's
going to be hard so this is part of the
deal i'm not hearing anything that to me
is is considered really stressful here's
what's interesting that you should kind
of think through
looking on the looking at this from the
outside looking in from our perspective
you want to sign up for dietitian school
which is really rigid you have to go to
the freaking class and pass the dadgum
test or you don't become a dietitian
and if you don't show up for class that
counts against you that's very rigid
but that does not stress you a bit uh
that makes sense the reason it didn't
stress you was it was taking you towards
your goal and you were
you knew it wasn't permanent gotcha
okay am i wrong no you're not
okay and so just look at the nursing job
is the same way it's not permanent or
the hospital job is the same way it's
not permanent it's getting you to your
goal
it's a temporary thing and as ken said
it is the
price of admission it's the price you
pay to get there
so well done well done that's thank you
for letting us talk that through with
you that was an honor
the future you're gonna be a big deal
yeah i think you're really gonna i mean
five years from today you're gonna be
sitting in a really really good place
something jennifer i want you to hear
and other people that are in her boat
when you're paying the price
you got on those tough days where you
feel like i'm in the slog and i'm not
doing it you better start to
envision some people in the future that
you may save their life
or their health because of the work
you're gonna do you better start to look
to the future
i'm doing this now that's not fun that's
very rigid
so that i can give dietary advice and
maybe prolong someone's life maybe
save their life absolutely the number
one disease in america is obesity
we need dietitians so no question well
done
that's very cool i mean listen there's a
difference in stress and just being
tired
that's right yeah i mean i get fatigued
a lot i don't have a lot of stress
because i just if i don't like what i'm
doing i just change it so it's fairly
easy
it's you know it's a wonderful thing and
the good news is guess what
all of you have that same opportunity
that puts
the ramsey show this hour in the books
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product
or service and didn't have a chance to
write it down don't worry
we list everything you've heard about
during this episode in the podcast show
notes section or head to the ramsay
show.com
thanks for listening
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey this is the ramsey show
ken coleman ramsey personality host of
the ken coleman show which is a show all
about your career
your jobs and doing the work that you
love is my co-host today so we'll take
calls about your money your life your
job your careers we're here
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five
two to five so guys over the last
13 or 14 months even pre pandemic
we have been planning the largest
tech project that this company has ever
worked on
and we want to make sure that we can be
there to help you guys to serve you guys
with the website with technology
platforms and so forth and we're always
looking at ways to do that and
why we do this is we take all our
possible resources we point them at
making you guys get better it's what we
do every day we want to help people
and like i said over the past 14 months
our team has been really working hard
and i'm telling you hundreds of people
with thousands
of man hours tens of thousands of man
hours
have been working on this to make it
easier
for you guys to find great content tools
to help you
products to help you services to help
you help you get connected to other
people
in the financial world that can uh serve
you
and take you you know make sure you get
the best possible deal on things
improve every aspect of your life and it
launched
today we've done the conversion from
daveramsey.com to
ramseysolutions.com
and again that involved tens of
thousands of man-hours there's over ten
thousand
links that had to be done there was two
thousand blogs
that had to be reset there were hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds of pages
that had to be reworked and set to make
this when we
flipped the switch last night to ramsey
solutions.com
it's slick it is working they did an
incredible job
all of their hard work and planning made
the
transition to the on this massive
website i mean it's freaking massive
uh they i'm so proud of our tech team
yeah they are they were heads down
man they were hustling and grinding it
was really fun you know
after our time together as a team uh on
monday
morning this afternoon he's like hey
training room's gonna be full this tech
team is coming together
it was fun to see the pictures uh
circulating these smart men and women i
don't even belong in the same room with
they're so smart but them all coming
together and working hard
because you're right it's a massive
undertaking and uh it's fun to see all
of that
uh it truly is extraordinary
how much work was done to change a site
like that
um and so now it's a one-stop shop you
can find everything you need to know ken
coleman rachel
tell people why we did anthony o'neil
christie wright dr john deloney
dave ramsey everything about ramsay plus
everything about all the elps and no
wild goose chase
very very easy to navigate lots of
detail
study went into the design the platform
the relook
the reskin uh the the graphics team the
creatives team
on the thing or just um the digital
creatives were just amazing
and i got to tell you we're really proud
of our tech team
and it's about half of our company
almost between digital and creative i
mean it's uh
it's you know hundreds and hundreds of
people here at
at all levels of expertise uh from entry
level to
extremely see extreme senior programmers
and so go check it out check it out for
us go to ramseysolutions.com
surf around a little bit um no salesman
will call nobody will bother you we're
not going to force you to do anything
uh but your go see how much easier it is
to find what you need
to uh to to go win with money to do what
it takes for you to do what you're
supposed to do
so you're going to hear us from this day
forward referring to ramsey
solutions.com
and uh not daveramsey.com because it's a
whole lot bigger deal around here than
just dave ramsey these days
uh thank goodness uh that was a fairly
limiting factor
well you know it's everything you come
to expect from daveramsey.com but so
much more as dave just said so
you know it's the same stuff you've
always wanted needed and it's just
better better more of it easier to
navigate it is a gorgeous site
on top of just functional great looking
site super easy to navigate so spread
the word
ramsay solutions.com robert is in baton
rouge hey robert welcome
to the ramsey show how can we help
hello gentlemen thank you for having me
on sure what's up
my uh my wife and i are 2010
fpu graduates who are living the dream
thank you by the way awesome i am
currently suffering from a severe case
of powder butt syndrome
73 she's on a fixed income and she's in
a losing battle with math
um i i've given you your book
i've told her the baby steps and um
i am failing miserably i was actually on
your website i like it i like it a lot i
was looking
at ramsay plus and i just want to know
if i put her in front of that and
click go can it help her
that's my question well um
it can help anyone who wants help
so my question is does she want help or
do you want her to have help
well i mean yeah she's giving me signs
that
they're to me a cry for help you know i
mean there's always been
we lost my father in in 2019
they've all been very close with their
thank you
i've always been very close about their
financial situation but
you know she's she's approached me in
tears
she's made some very poor financial
decisions so
is a lot of her uh hesitation just shame
possibly yeah very very possibly
she it was for me when i did stupid
stuff by the way
my biggest thing was i just felt stupid
i felt ashamed and i didn't
i didn't want to tell anybody
yeah i just wish your kid gotten some
advice before doing but yeah but she's
there now and she just feels bad
right yeah and your dad's con
you know and and so i mean she's not
even getting anybody left to blame at
home
she got to blame it on herself now she's
stuck
yeah we can help her i think she's more
ready than than the
than than she's able to verbalize and
we'll give it to her we always take care
of widows we're christians
and so uh you know she's got ramsay plus
for a year on us
thank you dude and um that'll put her
into financial peace university
uh does she use a smartphone
she has a smartphone and i i actually
bought her a
use a computer yes sir
okay so you know you help her download
the every dollar app
and let's get the budget system going on
the uh online
uh you know there's lots of 73 year olds
doing this stuff and it'll give her
a sense of peace when she to these
extent she has a sense of control
i don't hear this woman being obstinate
i hear her being scared
and ashamed and i think that you've
acknowledged that it's a cry for help
acknowledge it with her
and say mom i'm going to walk through
this with you it's still scary talk
about the times that you did some stupid
stuff robert
so she doesn't feel alone in it and hold
on kelly'll pick up will get her signed
up as our gift
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones here at
two two 825-5225 as we talk about your
careers your jobs your money
and your life shane is with us in
cincinnati hi shane how are you
hi i'm good how are you better than i
deserve how can we help
well i'm 22 and uh recently married and
my wife and i are on
baby step number two and we're wondering
if we should
use the money that we have saved to buy
a rental property
to like beef up our annual income and
attack the debt
then or to use the money that we have
saved now
and just going all in right now
how much money do you have saved shane
um
about 16 000 okay
no under no circumstances
you wanna know why yes you put fifteen
thousand dollars on a rental property
you're not gonna make any money
by the time you pay the payment after
the rent you have expenses you're going
to lose money every month
you don't have enough equity in the
property to actually freaking create a
cash flow
it's an illusion dude you need to stay
away from get rich quick channels on
youtube
okay so let me tell you what let me tell
you what happened to me okay
i graduated from college at 22 years old
with a degree in real estate
and i worked for a real estate company
for a little while and i started buying
and selling real estate all borrowed
money with almost no money down like you
have
almost no money i was broke when i
started
and with all borrowed money i bought
properties like
crazy and by the time i was 26 i had
four million dollars worth
with a little over a million dollar net
worth and i was making 200 000
a year doing flips and then rentals i
grew a portfolio
but i had almost no money and a lot of
real estate
the bank got sold to another bank
and i spent the next two and a half
years of my life losing everything i
owned
because i did with extra zeros on the
end what you're talking about doing
uh and now i own hundreds of millions of
dollars of real estate
you know 30 years after going bankrupt
uh and i paid cash for every bit of it
with wealth that i built and it has made
me even wealthier
real estate is something to make you
wealthier it is not something to
put fifteen thousand dollars down and
make a monthly income on you're going to
make a
huge mistake if you keep going down that
path there is no
shortcut in this process
that makes sense to you at all yes
yes yeah and let me tell you let me tell
you something else
you said you're married yes your wife
thought this was a dumb idea didn't she
um actually she's the one that
thought of it hello
okay i'm sorry i threw her under the bus
all right
i'm a little shocked okay well here's
the thing here's what
happens in our culture um
and it it happened to me um and the way
we grow up and see if this sounds right
to you we all
if you grow up without money which i
grew up without money and i'm kind of
thinking you did shane
okay okay we're looking at these people
with money
and they all seem to have real estate
and so we think then the connection that
we make in our brains because we don't
know any better because we didn't grow
up around wealth is that real estate
is what made them wealthy and
actually the data that we have on
millionaires says that
very few people become millionaires with
real estate
now here's what they do do
they do buy a lot of real estate as they
become wealthy and it makes them
wealthier but very few people start from
broke doing real estate deals
become wealthy and retain the wealth
because they usually have so much debt
that there's actually no cash flow
lots of risk and one little hiccup one
little covet gets loose
and um you know
and you get all kinds of problems and
you you end up in a worse
situation and so um there there's quite
a
um a movement happening among people
your age shane that says
real estate is the way to get rich
starting your own business is the way to
get rich
and when in reality you can start your
own business if you want
uh you spend a few dollars and make a
bunch of dollars if you want with a lot
of hustle
but but uh but real estate usually you
should buy
later on in your wealth building process
and it accelerates
what the wealth you've already built but
very very few people statistically
become wealthy
from nothing starting with and only
using real estate to do it does that
make sense ken
it makes total sense shane here's the
deal a young married couple i would be
working a lot of more extra hours you
want more income
get a better job or work another job and
that increase
income gets you through baby step two
faster you move into baby step three
and now all of a sudden you get to a
point if you walk the baby steps out
you guys could be there and you could be
saving up money then buy your first
house
you could have your house paid for and
buy your first rental by the time you're
30.
in cash if you just start walking these
baby steps and working your way out hold
on i'm going to send you a copy of the
book the total money makeover
and show you what we're talking about
you read it and then you decide for
yourself
chris is in new york city hi chris how
can ken and i help
hi dave thanks for taking my call always
appreciate it
i've been a long time watcher of yours
i've been watching you since i've been
about 17 18. but my
question is how do i set myself up for a
better future
currently i'm a college dropout
i work part-time jobs i make under 30
000 a year
and coming up soon i have to help out
with rent because uh my family's
finances aren't really the best i'm
basically the only breadwinner
how old are you and i'm 20.
okay and you're the only breadwinner
like you live with your mom and dad
you're going to be supporting them and
you're 20.
i live with my mom and my grandmother my
mom
is currently on disability she hasn't
worked for the past couple of years and
i'm the only one that works
all right can yeah so a couple things
here you
what what do you want for your future
because i understand the short term you
gotta you gotta make more money to help
mom and grandma out with the right
you're gonna be doing when you're 30
living with mom and grandma
that's not your vision no my
my vision is to you know get out of the
house
i i learned very late while i was going
through school what my actual career
path
uh what i want to do which is what i
learned that
i want to be a pilot i look through all
the steps
look through everything that i have to
do great but financially
i would you know be looking at you know
eighty thousand dollars in loans and
that
that number just kind of scares me well
no it's not eighty thousand dollars in
loans uh
i will tell you it is very expensive no
question about it to to get that license
but there
are a couple ways to go about that and i
think for you you want to be flying
and i think there are multiple ways to
do that and so you've got to look at do
i need to do
this type of training to get in there or
can i work my way get in the aviation
industry make some great connections
start making more money you go any
industry you want to
because it's the day job that's going to
fund the dream job so why don't you
investigate the international guard
i i agree i think you're looking at that
to to get that flight experience
or even the air force the air force they
pay for your for your education
uh you've got to get real serious right
now you're not stuck
you're scared there's a big difference
and let me tell you what people get
scared of
the lack of a plan you don't know the
details you need to look at
international guard the air force you
need to look at
multiple ways that you could eventually
get that pilot's license to do what you
want to do
the more information you have now the
less scary it is
and so you're absent of knowledge you're
not stuck
but then i will tell you as a young man
right now you better get after it
you can be doing more you could be
making more money to help out mom and
grandma and i'd be encouraging mom to be
doing something from home too
even in a disability situation yeah i
would sit down with a recruiter for the
air national guard
and i would sit down with a recruiter
for the air force and learn about what
your options are what they will pay for
what kind of sign up bonuses and
processes that they have
that will get you out of the house and
that will turn you into a pilot if
you're qualified
and air force pilots you know
uh they walk into commercial air not
it's not unusual at all
no into a career in flying and so um
and for that matter chartered air and
other
miscellaneous jets that you have the
opportunity to fly
so i would investigate that and at 20
years old
it might be the answer to a whole lot of
structure and a whole lot of things that
would be great for you
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host
today zack is on the line in fort worth
texas and my screen says you're
debt-free zach congratulations
thank you so much well done well done
how much have you paid off
uh 38 six hundred seventy dollars
and twenty one months phenomenal and
your range of income during that time
uh fifty five thousand to sixty five
thousand cool what do you do for a
living
i am a teacher and coach oh wow well
thank you we're doing
our teacher appreciation giveaway right
now at ramseysolutions.com so you
need to sign up for that man we're going
to give away 5 000 bucks to say thank
you to some teacher
so it's uh well done man so hey so what
kind of debt was the 39 000
uh it was all student loans okay cool
how old are you i am actually turned 26
today today is my birthday
oh cool so you got out of school and
21 months ago something happened and lit
you up to knock this out fast what
happened coach
uh well i had just graduated and my
parents paid for me to go to
uh fbu and me and one of my best friends
from high school is one of my groomsmen
at my wedding that i have in 18 days as
well
is we went to the class together and i
had just gotten my first paycheck with a
comma in it
and was excited and so
i had all this money that i had never
made before
and i needed a plan i had always been a
saver
my dad taught me from a young age to
save 10
of everything that i ever made and
that's exactly what i had done and
it gave me a game plan and i'm greatly
greatly appreciative
of you and your course and how it helped
me
get myself out of debt and it has really
set me up for my future
uh with my with my future wife i'm
really excited about it
very cool well congratulations man
debt-free and getting married in 18 days
life's pretty good so where's the fiance
on all this subject
well fiance is actually she became debt
free
about a year ago and so we are getting
married i'm
26 she just turned 25 and getting
married and neither one of us have any
debt we're already
through baby step three with our
six-month emergency fund and we have a
pretty good sized uh
down payment on a house for when we get
one
well done man touchdown i love it baby
that's awesome very very cool so
uh mom and dad give you the course when
you come out come out of college and go
okay now get this student loan cleaned
up how was it you didn't
i mean a lot of people might have bowed
up and said i'll do whatever i want to
do
why did you believe that you should do
that
well i i always i always believed that i
could do
things that nobody else could and i knew
so many people
who were paying off student loans 10 15
20 years down the road and i did not
want to do that
i actually listened to one of your
podcasts a couple years ago
and you had said that you were going
over the top
five professions that end up everyday
millionaires
and teachers are one of those top five
yep
and i thought you know if if
they can do it i can do it and i take
pride in doing something that
people say is impossible and that's
exactly what i'm going to do i'm
i'm planning on becoming an everyday
millionaire everyday multi-millionaire
and
being a teacher all the same wow i don't
think there's any question you're going
to do that
with that what you do to increase your
income by ten thousand
uh i took up coaching so i started off
and i wasn't a coach
and i uh i'm now coaching three sports i
coach football
uh powerlifting and uh track and field
and actually as soon as i get off the
phone i'm headed to a track meet tonight
nice wow well congratulations so
obviously mom and dad were big
cheerleaders the fiance was a big
cheerleader who else
uh my i have uh i have co-workers
that that listen to you and i have
multiple friends that
have actually led your fpu class
themselves
um and i've been keeping them updated
with what i've been doing
i was keeping them updated that i'd be
on the show today and everybody's super
excited for me and
i've had people i posted on facebook
that i was debt-free and they were
very excited i had messages coming in
how in the world did you do it and
the the number one thing i told them was
the budget and i gave them the every
dollar app
that the every dollar app has been a
great
great tool in staying on track
and sacrificing things that
a lot of my friends were doing i
couldn't we didn't we don't go out to
eat very much we don't
we don't go to the movies we don't go on
a whole lot of trips um
we we stick to the budget and that's the
plan
and it's really easy to do
how does it how does it feel now that
you did it
it feels like a huge weight off my
shoulders i'm
i can look forward to the future i can
look forward to
getting a house with my with my almost
wife and
having kids and being able to help them
with college and help pay for their
college and give them a life that
i've always that i've always wanted to
give them i actually wrote one of my
college entrance essays was
about a long-term goal and i wrote about
the long-term goal about being a good
dad
and this is this is my first step on
being a good dad being financially
stable and being able to provide for
them
that's so good zach i you said something
earlier about the co-workers i thought
that was so beautiful
talk to people that are listening right
now about the importance of community
people
that are like-minded on this journey and
that they can encourage you when
everybody else is still going out to eat
and going to the movies and
what's in what what is the effect that
it has on a person when they've got
community
well if i think that and even i do the
same thing with my students
is if you give them encouragement
and tell them they're doing the right
thing rather than telling them
what they're trying to accomplish isn't
possible it makes it a lot easier
mentally um to be able to accomplish it
if you've got people in your corner
telling you man what you're doing is
awesome you are setting up your future
you can absolutely do this i'm rooting
for you
please let me know every step of the way
if you ever need any help or anything
that kind of support behind you
goes miles oh it does uh and it's
it was really awesome to have yeah i
have a button you have a lot of positive
a lot of positive peer pressure around
you instead of people telling you all
the time you can't be done
exactly yeah yeah you surround yourself
with people in
any situation that are that are that way
you're gonna you're gonna
much higher probability of success so
well zach we're very proud of you
brother congratulations
very very well done thank you so much
for calling in to do your debt free
screen we've got a copy of rachel cruz's
latest
new york times bestseller it's called
know yourself
know your money and we'll send that out
to you to say
uh as a wedding gift and a as a
a prize for doing your debt-free scream
so very well done what's your fiancee's
first name
ashley all right so zach on behalf of
zach and ashley 18 days away
fort worth texas 39 000 paid off in 21
months
making 55 to 65. count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
[Music]
way to go coach i love it
man future's so bright absolutely incr
incredible very very well done uh
misty is on facebook uh and she says i'm
42 years old and i work as a respiratory
therapist i really
want to go back to nursing school for
better advancement do you think i'm too
old
no for heaven's sakes you're not too old
you're 42 years young
um you know when people ask that am i
too old question there's a lot bottled
up in that day
number one it's an insecurity and it and
and it comes from you know you're
advancing in age you're in your 40s now
and you go i'm not
22 anymore will they hire a 42 year old
or in this case maybe a 44 or 46 year
old nurse
uh if i'm competing against gals that
are 25 and 26 and that's a false
narrative
you know they're gonna hire the person
that they think is best for the job
whether you're 42
32 22. so no you're not too old not at
all
if you're 82 we'll talk about it yeah
that that's going to be an issue
i think hiring 82 year old nurse is
probably an issue for reasons that i'm
unable to articulate
with intelligence but i mean seriously
not 42. yeah
no no you're you're able-bodied and
you'll bring a lot of maturity and
wisdom to the job that
um that the youngsters might know
you're fine freaking 42 is not old i'm
60 and i'm not old so shut up
seriously there you go my gosh
this is the ramsey shadow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture today jeremiah 17 7 but
blessed is the one who trusts in the
lord whose confidence
is in him jerry rice said today
i do what others want so that tomorrow i
can accomplish
what others don't chris
is in orlando hey chris welcome to the
ramsey show
how can we help hey dave thanks for
taking my call
um been a long time listener and your
program has helped me and my family out
tremendously
my question today is really on behalf of
my mom um
she's in a bit of a pickle she's never
been the one to handle financial stuff
and my father just passed away about two
and a half weeks ago oh my gosh
trying to figure yeah it's been it's
been pretty rough
and she she's just now me and my sisters
are we're working with her to get
her you know kind of get financial
things in order
um my question is that she was just
served
some papers regarding a past debt from
2005
that has gone to collections and has now
been assigned to
an attorney it's now passed judgment
a judge has signed off on it so she's
getting ready to be hit
with uh have her wages garnished
the um the original amount was about 12
000 um but it's now gone up to it's
about 24
000. um so my mom contacted them today
and i kind of coached her through you
know don't give out any information
no checking account none of that just
let them know that you're just asking
questions and
that you receive the paperwork and um i
know that
we'd like to try to find some way to
settle but their first offer
was about 21 000 which
my mom doesn't have um
she has a little bit that i think we
could scrape together
but seeing how this situation has
already
is about to go that she's about to start
being garnished i know that we don't
have a lot of
who said she's about to be garnished
so my my mom was about two hours away
from me
and my sister took pictures of all the
documents she sent them to me and so
i have um like the court orders in front
of me in fact
my mom thought it was she she thought
that they could have been fake they went
to the clerk of the court they verified
all the documents
and the the paperwork that she's been
given is saying that she has you know um
x amount of days to file a response
if she's going to claim exemption
on the garnishment based on the
available options
i don't believe she will qualify for an
exemption
does she live in florida yes
okay and how old is she
66 and what kind of money does she have
she's still working she makes about
thirty thousand
dollars a year um
i i do believe that you said that you
said she could scrape together some
money and it was a little bit and you
guys could help and it was a little bit
what's the total
the um i don't know exactly what we
could
put together just yet because with my
dad
passing she's not she's a renter she's
not going to be renewing her lease and
so we're going to be looking at trying
to
downsize to save her as as much
as much as possible so there's going to
be a move happening but i i do
think that we could probably get you
know between five and
i think between maybe five and ten
thousand dollars put together between
what she has and what me my sisters
could throw in
i just i'm gonna go down and spend some
time with her next week i just didn't
know if you had
any advice in terms of like if this does
go to garnishment which it looks like
the judge has signed off on it it's been
verified by the clerk of the court
unless she files an exemption she's
going to be garnished
so we don't have a lot of you know
there's we don't have a dog in
there what does she just saying what
does she do what's her job
she's she worked for a
hospital on the you know the front end
staff doing she's a receptionist she
helps out in the in the child's care
um she's been with them for you know for
years and
um okay so uh
here's here's what i want you to try um
first and you'll you'll need to jump
online and pull a form
or just make up on giving you permission
to discuss her account
and have her sign it and your name and
her social security number and
everything on it
that you can fax to this attorney and
then you get on the phone
with this attorney and here's how it
sounds all right
that you need to remember this attorney
is not a
um this is not matlock
this is not some real big attorney this
is a
collections attorney and your mother's
account is one of
ten thousand accounts that they're
working right now she's a widget in a
factory
there's no emotion there's no big drama
there's no big
uh anything going on here okay and so uh
they're they just want some money that's
all they want and they have no soul
at all when you're talking to them all
right
and here's what you're gonna say my mom
is 66
my dad passed away two and a half weeks
ago
she makes only thirty thousand dollars a
year so let me tell you what you folks
are gonna get
zero because i'm taking her straight to
the bankruptcy attorney and we're gonna
file a chapter seven
and you're gonna get nothing
or we're gonna come to terms with a
deeply discounted settlement on the
phone
today if you screw with me
i'm leaving with my mother in five
minutes
to visit the bankruptcy attorney chapter
seven
you're gonna get zero don't screw with
me
i've got six thousand dollars you need
to take it because it's all you're gonna
get from this broke little widow
don't screw with me chapter
chapter set chapter seven yeah chapter
seven bankruptcy is a traditional
bankruptcy in which all
unsecured creditors get zero you're not
gonna follow chapter seven
you're bluffing okay
but get all up in their face and explain
to them this is a 66 year old widow
it's my mother i'm highly offended at
this situation
my brothers and sisters and i've scraped
together six thousand dollars we can
offer you that
and that is all and you will take it in
this phone call
don't screw with me because let me tell
you when you get somebody on the phone
on the other end what you have
is a collector and you're dealing with a
credit card collector
which by definition is scum and so once
you do get
agreement and you're going to have to
pound them are you ready to roll up your
sleeves and stiffen your backbone
because it's going to be a mean
tough conversation because you're
dealing with soulless human beings you
with me
absolutely yeah i'm with you you are
fighting on behalf of your mother in
this conversation
and then you get it in writing from this
soulless creature
that they will accept six thousand
dollars from this 66 year old widow
and then you send them the six thousand
dollars and you do not give them any
information
on her nowhere are you going to find her
now your worst case scenario is she goes
and gets another job and they never find
her
if uh and that would be like a money
order that you would just yeah
money order you could get a you could
get a prepaid debit card
and a single usage but no electronic
access to her checking account or yours
okay and then what you said a paper that
has to be facts of the attorney that
gives you rights to speak on my mom's
behalf do you know the name of that
paper
it's just you're just it's a simple
paragraph that says that right there
oh okay okay just something that is
in-house
okay yeah there there may be did you go
through financial peace university at
any time
i did not go through that we used to put
those forms in the back of the books a
thousand years ago there might be one in
the back of an old financial peace book
out there uh that we never put them in
the total money makeover books
so if you've got one of those laying
around but it's not that big a deal you
just write up a paragraph says i so and
so give
so and so permission my social security
number so and so to act on my behalf
uh and please just and uh you know
permission to discuss this account and
negotiate on my behalf
my son my son chris and just and your
name and her name and it doesn't have to
be a big deal
just something that you can uh scan and
email to them so that
because they're not supposed to discuss
your account her account with anyone but
her
it's illegal under privacy law but dude
that
you're about to enter the you're about
to enter a whole different world here
be ready for the fight ken good show
today thanks for having me always good
fun
james childs kelly daniels in the booth
thank you for a great show i am dave
ramsey your host we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace
christ jesus hey guys this is james
senior producer for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
[Music]
thermsyshow.com
you